if you live in the area that has been affected by Hurricane
you need one of these I never realized how much pollution and bacteria
and all that went into the air after Hurricane
until Hurricane had a dragon
and I got so sick with cold toxicity
and I had no idea that that was a thing that could happen
and so one of the things that my doctor recommended was getting air
air fires for our whole home
because we can't control what the air quality is like outside
but what we can control is what the quality of air is inside our home
and air air fires are fantastic for that
okay last year
we have invested in air purifiers for every room in the house
this one is for the homeschool room
and I can rest easy
knowing that the air we're breathing every day while we're schooling
is nice and clean